Ms is a very unique disease to everyone
that has it you can meet someone who's
the same age as you got diagnosed the
same day as you had the same everything
and your journey with the disease can be
totally opposite of each other like I've
had it for I've been D I was diagnosed
in 2012 and 11 years and I'm there's
nothing I can't do like I I do Jiu-Jitsu
four days a week well that's what I was
going to say that
you when you hear Ms that's a devast
ating I remember working with Sharon at
the time it was devastating yeah you
know you're her baby boy you're always
regardless of how old you are you're
always a baby boy I was I was oh my God
you hear a child has
Ms um and then throughout the years I've
been watching you do uh climbing
mountains and doing Fitness things and
like beyond what anybody that has no
diagnosis I feel like every show you do
is either ghost or challenges you're
challenging your body to like reach the
max did you find a cure no um I don't
know if I found a cure uh because if you
if I like my I'm I'm the world's worst
MS patient I'll tell you that like if a
doctor says don't do that or do it I'm
like me like I I don't I haven't
taken my meds in a very long time you
don't take your meds no no and it's
so this is the kind of person I am so
the do the doctor's like all right take
these meds you know it'll it'll help
whatever um and I was doing it for a
long time and then I had the thought of
like well what happens if I stop taking
my meds how long can I go without a
significant like flare up that was five
years what is a flare up tell me what a
flare up is so a flare up uh the way Ms
attacks your body it's an autoimmune
disease where your nerve your uh your
immune system basically goes nerve
endings bad let's attack them and so it
erodes this fatty sheath around your
nerves which is called milin and so it
demines the nerve exposes the kind of
core of the nerve like think of it as
like the copper inside of a wire okay um
and that will break down over time so
when you have a flare up it means like
oh your body's gone into like it's it's
state of inflammation it's attacking a
nerve um and then eventually it will
subside is it painful like what did you
feel how did you know you had Ms so what
prompted me to go to the hospital was I
went blind in my right eye like fully I
was I had about maybe 5 or 10% of my
peripheral vision you just woke up one
day and you couldn't see it it was over
three days so like I woke up and I had
like a black dot in the middle of my my
vision and then um throughout the day it
kind of got bigger and bigger and then
within 3 days I had you know all central
vision was just gone so I did what any
normal person does when there's a
problem with your eye you go to the eye
doctor and you're like what's going on
and and then they sent me to the
hospital and I had all the test done and
they were like no this is Ms because
they they determined it was Ms not only
because of the test but 18 months prior
my legs went numb for like 3 months and
me just being a
25-year-old you know knucklehead I was
just like oh I pinched a n and my back
I'll be fine and I just you know
eventually the you know the feeling came
back to my legs but you you you were
walking around with numb legs yeah and
it was the strangest kind of numbness
too because like I couldn't really like
it it felt like like um like when I
touched my legs the feeling it felt was
like my legs were Play-Doh it was just
weird and then if hot water touched my
legs it felt icy cold and if cold water
touched my legs it felt burning hot and
you didn't go the first day you didn't
go to the no this is the difference
between you and I Howie big difference I
I am like the I'm like there's there's
you know people who have take you know
who very hyper concerned about that
stuff and then there's people who just
like I don't care actually you guys are
very similar he he is very concerned
about everyone around him and his family
and will make you go to the doctor as
soon as you say that there's an issue he
won't oh okay but I'm afraid of the
doctor but I'm afraid of catching
something there there'll be other sick
people there but if my I would imagine
that if my legs were uh playo I might no
at least go to the eye doctor
yeah do you wait how do you have doctors
come to you uh no no you went to the
doctor yesterday no oh yeah I went to do
I had to go get shots cuz I'm going out
of town but but uh um my point is these
as you describe your um experience for
most people listening and watching
that's pretty harrowing yeah so now you
get
diagnosed and they say to you you need
these medications because the the
prognosis you're given by the
traditional doctor is what what did they
say to you well they
in my experience they they they never
really gave you they can't give you a
prognosis other than like hey you've got
this disease his where it could go but
it might not we don't know because
there's so many it's like I said it's
it's literally as unique to the
individual that has it as their own
fingerprint it is it it there's no um
did you get depressed I got really I got
bummed out because I and and I was yeah
I was depressed cuz it was like I had
pull was 3 weeks old when I got
diagnosed I you know I was 27 28 and I
was like cool like I'm you know this is
a great time in my life and you know I'd
been sober for a while at that point and
I was like
well what the was this like what's
the point in any of this you know so I
had that for a short window uh and then
I was H and then I ended up at a place
where it was well I've got this baby and
I have to take care of her and I you
know was with I was with my ex-wife at
the time and I
I was I had to Pony up
really